okay we're gonna play i gotta play this
um from the hill says the mother of a
transgender boy in texas went viral this
week after making an emotional plea to
state lawmakers about a bill that would
make it illegal for parents to provide
gender affirming health care
gender affirming health care quotes
around that procedures for their
children under the bill parents aiding
their
transgender children and receiving
medical care including puberty
suppressant drugs medical procedures and
hormone replacement therapy
would be labeled abusers and their
actions would be considered a felony
if the child is under the age of 18.
great law
but amber briggle um who's the
mother of a quote unquote trans boy
didn't like it she spoke out during the
legislative
session and this went uh this went viral
a lot of you
you go girl type type of responses from
the left
let's let's listen to what she had to
say good afternoon
my name is amber brigel and i am
terrified
to be here today i'm terrified because
i'm the parent of a transgender child
and i'm afraid that by speaking here
today my words will be used against me
should sb 1646 or sb 1311 pass
and my sweet son whom i love more than
life itself
will be taken from me
but here i am i want you to know how
hard it is for me to be here today not
only am i terrified for the future of my
family
but i'm a small business owner with two
children at home who are still going to
public school 100
online i have a million better things to
do than be here today
like rebuilding my business and
supervising my children's online
learning and repairing the damage that
occurred
to my home when the electric grid failed
but this committee and the bill's
authors
somehow deems my son's private medical
care
more important than covet relief for
women women-owned small businesses
or making public schools safer or fixing
ercot
okay i want to stop it there for just
one second
um she has about three and a half
minutes we're not gonna play the whole
thing i'll have some mercy on you but
she has about three and a half minutes
to
make her point give her a little speech
now we're almost
a half of the way into it um over a
third of the way into it
and you notice what like
a minute 15 seconds out of three minutes
i me my
this is all about her she spent the
first third at least
talking about herself that's
that should tell you something for these
parents
it's it's about them
okay that's that's this is not a
coincidence
this is almost always the case when you
listen to parents of quote-unquote trans
children
and you hear them make their case it it
it's it's
like mostly them and then they'll throw
in and we'll get to this in a second
and then they'll throw in their concerns
for their child
but the justification for how they're
treating their child and
and and the long-term effects on their
child and the well-being of their child
that's
really an afterthought it's it's it's
mostly about them
as far as her child goes let's listen to
uh what she has to say
son was four years old he asked me if
scientists could turn him into a boy
i didn't understand then that he was
trans
i only knew that he wasn't like most
girls his age and that something inside
him was hurting
like many of you i thought he was asking
for surgery and i freaked out
but after doing research i came to
understand that gender affirmation
surgery
isn't done on minors and that there is a
whole array of medical options available
for transgender youth
including hormone blockers which are 100
reversible
are not new and are clinically proven to
save the lives
of the trans children taking them okay
none of that is true by the way it's uh
it's all completely false
now it's it may be true that in most
cases
the surgical mutilation is is
going to happen after they turn 18
but but the conditioning and the
brainwashing leading to that
happens when they're young so the fact
that you're waiting until they turn 18
actually do this thing that you've
conditioned them for and brainwashed
them into for all these years you know
that
that to me doesn't make me feel any
better at all
um but what you're doing before that is
drugging them chemical castration before
you get to the
physical surgical castration again it
doesn't make me feel much better about
it
it doesn't make it any better what she
said about is a 100 percent totally
totally reversible that is bs
she she does not know nobody actually
really knows the full long-term effects
of this
because we've never done it on anything
approaching this scale ever before in
history this is a new thing
this generation of children they are the
guinea pig generation we don't actually
know
before this you have scattered cases
here and there but but but
this to this extent we have
not had a sample size put it this way we
haven't had a sample size big enough
to really know yet what the long-term
effects are
so all of these children with the rever
totally reversible and safe
uh puberty blockers
what what impact is that going to have
on them 20 years from now 30 years from
now
you don't really know you don't
you just hope that it works out
and even if it doesn't you your your
child's long-term
physical health and even short-term
physical health is um
a side issue that's not that's not the
primary thing for you
and then she says uh when my child was
four years old he came to me and said
can scientists turn me into a girl or no
it was a girl who's a boy now right
identifying as a boy let me rephrase
it's a girl whose mother
has identified her as a boy okay so she
says that when her
daughter was four she said can
scientists turn me into a boy
this is a really easy thing to handle as
a
as a parent it's not even a difficult
situation it's not
okay when your four-year-old says
something like that very easy
i don't even want to hear i i i it goes
too far for me when i hear conservatives
sometimes say well it's a
at least we have to admit this is a
difficult situation for parents
no it's not especially not at that age
now you've got a 16 year old who out of
nowhere and i've heard of cases like
this
16 year old out of nowhere comes home
one day and says i want to change
genders
that's difficult of course the response
from the parent you could you can never
go along with it
but it's not a simple thing to solve and
it's going to take therapy it's good
it's just
that that is is difficult that's painful
as a parent
for a four-year-old though not hard i
don't want to hear that it's hard it's
so hard i didn't know what to do
he's four she's four
you know what you say when the daughter
says can scientists change me into a boy
no they can't you're a girl and that's
that's a wonderful thing
oh but i i think i'm a boy it's okay
you're a girl it's okay go run along and
play
that's it that's all you have to do it
is it is really that simple and that
easy
uh unless you know
unless as a parent you were waiting for
something like that or maybe you planted
those seeds in your child's head
because this is munchausen syndrome by
proxy and you are planting this gender
dysphoria in the child's head
for your own purposes because you want
to parade your kid around
like a prop and show the world
how enlightened you are as parents
listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated